restez à la maison c'est l'ordre qui
martelaient aux français par les
autorités pour s'assurer du respect des
mesures de confinement
les policiers contrôlent les papiers de
ceux qui s'aventurent à l'extérieur
tout le monde y passe tout le monde sauf
une exception les sans papiers les sans
domicile fixe raf arpentent les rues
parisiennes depuis quinze ans il
comptait jusqu'ici sur les repas chaud
offert par les associations de secours
et sur la bienveillance d'amis pour voir
à son hygiène se fermer tout ça il ya
des poteaux leur époque douch y apparaît
quelque chose ou rien les populations
itinérantes sont plus vulnérables aux
maladies infectieuses comme la coville
19 la majorité souffre de maladies
pulmonaires il hygiène de vie dans la
rue augmente les risques de
contamination les mesures de confinement
permettent encore aux centres
d'hébergement temporaire et aux soupes
populaires de fonctionner mais le
personnel se fait rare l'absence de
masques inquiète beaucoup
vous savez les bénévoles les salariés
ils sont comme tout français à qui à
l'heure actuelle
chez secours populaire à paris les
bénévoles ont été équipés de masques et
de gants de protection
les maraudes s'est tournée à la
rencontre des sdf dans la rue sont donc
maintenus en ces temps anxiogène pour
tout le monde
lucie se préoccupe de ses habitués qui
souffrent pour la plupart de troubles
psychiatriques ou est-ce qu'ils sont ça
veut dire qu'ils ont peur aussi
est-ce qu'ils sont bien informés les
gens qu'on voit ce soir pour l'instant
c'est pas les gens qui sont dans la plus
grande précarité en tous les cas
psychologique et là bas ils sont pas là
donc on ne sait pas qui a ri fidèle au
poste pour un petit café mais surtout ce
soir pour les fameuses justificatif de
déplacement dérogatoire ya pas la notion
de se dire moi je suis une personne
vulnérable
mais c'est pour ça que je me déplace à
la rencontre de quelqu un accord donc il
faut rajouter à la main ouais bon feria
mal mais je pense que c'est comme ça que
ceux perçus
prochain arrêt il faut bien rappeler les
nouvelles règles de distanciation
sociale non mais tu sais on peut pas
trop se touchent et d'idées ben oui mais
s'il faut essayer de respecter - jarry a
recommandé jean raison rien la ville de
paris doit ouvrir des places
d'hébergement 150 me pour ceux qui sont
atteints de lakovic 19 dès aujourd'hui
mais c'est loin de combler les besoins
d'eurofins brûle encore isabelle
s'inquiète mais elle conserve son sens
de l'humour et du spectacle
on est au bal masqué monsieur bal masqué
ici marie-eve bédard radio canada barry